roughly 66 million years ago our planet
went through one of the most large-scale
extinction events in the history of
multicellular life-forms
entire classes of species were wiped off
the face of the earth
others changed beyond all recognition in
order to adapt to the new conditions and
survive
the reasons for this dramatic event are
still not known for certain
still there is no doubt that the
cretaceous paleogene extinction made
great changes to what our planet looked
like
the majestic and horrifying dinosaurs
were superseded by creatures not less
impressive
mammals
three-fourths of all living organisms on
earth died out in the cretaceous
paleogene extinction almost all
creatures heavier than 25 kilos ceased
to be including practically all
non-avian dinosaurs
this tragic event heralded the end of
the mesozoic and the beginning of the
cenozoic the geologic era that is still
not over it is divided into three
periods of various duration which are
different both in terms of climate and
diversity of the biosphere
the first and longest is known as the
paleogene
it began around 66 million years ago and
continued for 43 million years
in the first 10 million years of the
paleogene the earth's biosphere was
recovering from the hard blow dealt by
the mass extinction
this geological epoch is referred to as
the paleocene
since great numbers of dinosaurs and
other species of the cretaceous had
perished there were lots of vacant
ecological niches for the taking these
were promptly filled by the new masters
of our planet
mammals
the geography of the earth of that
period was drastically different from
what we're used to seeing today
looking at a map of that prehistoric
earth we would already be able to make
out the familiar continents but they
were positioned slightly differently
thus north and south americas were
separated by tropical seas while the
indian subcontinent was just starting to
make for the asian shores
the prehistoric ocean known as the
tethers still lay between africa and
eurasia but was already largely giving
way due to the movements of tectonic
plates the climate of the epoch was
warmer and more stable than today's most
of the planet was covered with dense and
lush tropical forests
the overwhelming majority of the living
creatures of the day were quite small
thanks to the abundance of vegetable
food they quickly propagated and spread
across more and more new areas this is
when the prehistoric ancestors of most
of today's mammals thrived
for example the warm forests of the
paleogene were inhabited by my acids
small and deft predators that looked
like martins it is believed that they
were the progenitors of all today's rich
diversity of mammal predators
at around the same time their lived
archaeo seats the prehistoric ancestors
of today's whales at the time however
they looked more like hippos they hadn't
gone to live in the sea yet but had made
their first steps in that direction
their limbs respiratory organs in the
inner rear had already started to adapt
to prolonged stays underwater
the next step our planet went through
was the ear scene
it began approximately 56 million years
ago and continued for slightly over 22
million years the contours of the
continents had already grown to be quite
recognizable
india had finally made it to the
southern shores of asia and as a result
of the collision of tectonic plates
giant rock folds formed
that is how the himalayas rose
the largest mountain range on our planet
today
even though some species of that time
already looked like some we might come
across today others were completely
different
an example of one of these is andrew
sarkis
one of the largest mammal predators that
has ever lived on the earth
its skull measured up to 84 centimeters
which is roughly one and a half times
more than that of the brown bear and its
bite is estimated to have been harder
than that of any of today's land
predators
it has been inferred from the deep tooth
sockets in andrew sarkis's skull where
mandible muscles were attached to which
leaves no doubts as to the bite's
crushing force
reconstruction of its skeleton shows
that the animal could measure over 4
meters in length and weigh as much as a
ton
still interestingly it looks like this
giant carnivore fell into the class of
primitive angulates
research showed that andrew sarkis's
closest relatives were the prehistoric
sewer forms hippopotamus and cetaceans
studies of a few unearthed fossils with
skull and teeth show that the animal
must have been omnivorous and even
didn't mind eating carrion
unfortunately not many bones and fossils
of this fascinating creature have been
found
and scientists are still at odds as to
the structure of its organism habits and
relation to other mammal families
the oligoscene was the last debuck of
the paleogene it is posited that it
began around 33.9 million years ago and
was over about 23 million years ago
which makes it roughly 11 million years
long
this was a time of global cooling
warm tropical forests were gradually
superseded by endless prairies covered
with grasslands
this is when the antarctic glaciation
began and an icy shield transformed the
green continent of the pearl into a
lifeless cold desert
australia continued to drift away from
the other continents while africa on the
contrary was making for the north to
meet europe
after a collision of tectonic plates
mountain ranges formed and that is how
the alps made their appearance on the
map of the world
around 26 28 million years ago the super
volcano lagarita furiously erupted on
the territory of today's colorado
in fact it was one of the major volcanic
emissions of the entire phanerozoic eon
an area of over 30 000 square meters was
buried under a layer of hot ash as much
as a hundred meters thick all life
within a huge radius around the volcano
was destroyed completely
amazingly
life is able to come to terms with any
disasters
the earth of the time was inhabited by
fascinating creatures some of which were
not smaller than dinosaurs in size for
example intricate theorem a prehistoric
herbivore related to rhinos
paraceratherium the largest of these
reached 4.8 meters in shoulder length
which is higher than a large african
elephant
thanks to their remarkably long neck
these giants were able to raise their
head up to seven meters above the ground
today's rhino would be able to pass
under its enormous progenitor's belly
while a human would hardly reach up to
touch its knee
with our mass reaching 20 tons these
giants were the largest land mammals of
all times
even brontosaurus the most massive of
land dinosaurs weighed just around 15
tons it still hasn't been established
for certain what endrick ethereum looked
like unfortunately
not one entire skeleton of these amazing
animals has been excavated so far only
separate fragments from different
animals of the species
most scientists agree that in spite of
their relation to rhinos enduric
ethereum didn't have a massive horn
although it may well have had a small
nose trunk like today's tapias
the trunk would have allowed it to pick
juicy leaves off treetops
this giant herbivores must have lived in
small herds and were constantly on the
move around vast stretches of land
roaming across their dominions in search
of food
unfortunately by the end of the
oligoscene indrick ethereum had died out
completely
at around the same time the areas they
used to inhabit were explored by
prehistoric elephants alongside large
predators hyena dawns and damphi
cyanides the latters are also known as
bear dogs
it is thought that the emergence of new
large herbivores would have greatly
upset nature's balance and intricate
theorem would have been forced to
fiercely compete for its food
famine and the threat from the new
dwellers of the asian prairie gradually
led to the herbivores giant's total
extinction apart from those mentioned
there were some other large predators
who were quite common on the earth in
the period from 37.2 to 28.4 million
years ago
and teledance fossilized remains of
these creatures have been found all over
eurasia
being even toed ungulates and telodons
resembled wild boars although in terms
of evolution these creatures are closer
to hippos or even cetaceans measuring up
to two meters in length they weighed
over a ton a meter long head had huge
jaws complete with all sorts of teeth
sharp in sizes long fangs and wide flat
moles it is likely that intelligence
were omnivores with a preference for
predation not hampered by their
impressive size and bulk they were able
to develop remarkably high speeds so
chances of outrunning such a monster
were quite thin
a wild boar the size of a large bull
that prefers meat posed a serious threat
to any inhabitant of the earth of that
time
that is why it is hardly surprising that
intellidons successfully struggled for
their survival for such a considerable
time
the period in the history of our earth
that came next was the near gene
it began approximately 23 million years
ago and ended just two million five
hundred and eighty thousand years ago
this is when our planet started to look
almost but not quite what it looks like
today
the continents shifted to their today's
positions on the planet's surface and
the looks of the most of the plants and
animals of the day grew to be familiar
to our eye with the earth's climate
gradually becoming colder and with
droughts occurring more often polar caps
were gradually growing which culminated
in a global glaciation at the end of the
neogene
the planet meanwhile was crawling with
all sorts of fascinating creatures
the deep sea dwellers were terrorized by
megalodon a giant shark measuring 15
meters in length and weighing up to 35
tons
on land
various gomphotheriums could be seen
creatures related to today's elephants
many of them were the proud owners of
four solid tusks as for the animals size
some were larger than today's african
elephant whereas others were quite
modest in comparison
around 2.5 million years ago there
started the quaternary which is
currently the last geologic period in
the history of the earth it is
remarkable for the emergence and
evolution of homo sapiens as well as its
prehistoric ancestors
for example in the period from one
million years ago to a hundred thousand
years ago there lived gigantopithecus
one of the species of great human-like
apes known to science they measured
three to four meters in height and
weighed over 500 kilograms
these creatures lived on the territory
of asia and were related to today's
orangutans
it appears that gigantopithecus would
not be able to climb trees like other
human-like apes on account of its mass
however some of them are known to have
dwelt in mountainous areas and made
homes and natural grottos caves and
ravines
even though their diet is believed to
have consisted of mainly bamboo
bones of herbivorous animals with tooth
marks were unearthed in their shelters
judging by these finds it is safe to
assume that these creatures didn't mind
meat and were omnivorous at the very
least the gigantopithecus skeleton is
similar to that of a gorilla so they
were likely to use all four limbs to
move around
besides these human-like apes had a
comparatively large brain which means
that they could be relatively
intelligent and were probably able to
even make primitive working tools
unfortunately the population of these
amazing giants sharply dropped when the
prehistoric ancestors of today's human
emerged and spread across the planet
by around one to three hundred thousand
years ago they had died out completely
sadly not many remains of
gigantopithecus have been found which
greatly impedes studying them
as they were spreading across the earth
primitive human tribes eliminated many
other creatures
one of their victims was megatherium a
giant grounds human tribes came to south
america the powerful but sluggish giant
was helpless under a barrage of sharp
spears and arrows and very soon its
population dropped to zero
other giants who supposedly became
extinct because of humans were
diprotodons which inhabited australia in
the period from 1.6 million years ago to
around 40 000 years ago
these creatures were the largest known
marsupials and they were related to
wombats and koalas some of these amazing
animals reached as much as three meters
in length and two meters in shoulder
height as for their mass they weighed
approximately three tons
this makes diprotodons quite as big as
some hippos
massive and herbivorous they dwelt on
massive woodland and coastal
grass-covered plains that abounded in
australia before humans had made their
appearance there
chronologically the extinction of the
marsupial giants coincides with first
human tribes arriving to this continent
still some scientists maintained that
the extinction was caused not by hunting
but an anomaly of the earth's magnetic
field together with a local temperature
decrease the height and radiation
background coupled with cooling slowed
down plant growth which led to famine
among the herbivores
thus it appears that by and large the
tragedy was inevitable and the humans
simply brought it to a close faster
the last debacle of the quaternary the
holocene heralded a robust development
of the human civilization when homo
sapiens spread across the entire planet
and dominated all the other inhabitants
of our earth the downside of this
evolution is manifested in a number of
industrial disasters and irreversible
changes in nature's balance
for example it is due to human activity
that the greenhouse gases concentration
in the earth's atmosphere is getting
worse every year
this may globally negatively affect all
living things on our earth from simplest
bacteria to elaborate multicellular
organisms
unfortunately the number of fascinating
creatures living on our earth is going
down every year it is particularly
poignant to realize that they perish
because of human stupidity or roveries
on controlled hunting irresponsible land
development and indifference to the
environment have already made scientists
speak of a new sixth grade extinction
event
whose consequences are potentially just
as grave as those of the previous five
will mankind stop before it eliminates
itself
how long should it take our planet to
recover from the consequences of the
technological progress
and will nature produce radically new
life forms that would weather this
crisis
just like it happened before
we can hardly realistically answer these
questions
have a chat with your friends about this
if you feel strongly about the issues
raised here and give us a thumbs up if
you enjoyed the video
as you know it takes us a lot of time
and effort to make every video
interesting and informative
and your support means the world to us
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you